president biden leaves the white house
on his first international trip
since taking office hoping to show the
world that america is different with him
in charge his schedule
includes meetings with allies from the
g7 countries
a visit with queen elizabeth and a
face-to-face meeting with russian
president vladimir putin
wisha chang is at the white house wija
how's the president been preparing for
this trip
good morning anthony his press secretary
says that president biden has been
preparing for
50 years for this trip and in many ways
he has first as the chair of the senate
foreign relations committee
and then as vice president but now it is
his turn
to set the agenda the president will
kick off his trip by meeting with
british prime minister boris johnson on
thursday before attending the g7 summit
in cornwall england
it'll be the first time the leaders of
the world's largest economies will meet
face to face since the pandemic began
mr biden has stressed he wants to renew
america's commitment to allies
after his predecessor sparred openly
with them
his goal to rally the world's
democracies on issues like the pandemic
climate change and countering china he
and the first lady will then visit queen
elizabeth at windsor castle on sunday
before heading to brussels for the nato
summit the agenda there is expected to
include
defense spending cyber security and
russian aggression
mr biden will cap off the trip wednesday
with his first in-person meeting
with putin since becoming president now
his advisors say that
is not about delivering deals but rather
setting boundaries with russia
on everything from those cyber attacks
we've been seeing to its nuclear program
anthony luigi the president's leaving
just as talks with republicans
on an infrastructure deal fell apart
yesterday why did the president walk
away from those negotiations
the two sides just couldn't reach a deal
when it came to the scope
of a package and how to pay for it the
white house wanted to invest
one trillion dollars of news investments
in the measure but the gop
only offered about 330 billion dollars
the president wanted to change the
corporate tax
rates to help foot the bill while
republicans hope to repurpose
unspent coven 19 aid now a group of
bipartisan
bipartisan senators will try to hammer
out a proposal of their own and
president biden plans to keep in touch
with them
by phone while he's in europe anthony
louisa thank you very much